personnellement j'ai la conviction qu'on
a tout ce qu'il faut pour aller sur mars
on peut dire que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de dire qu'on va aller sur mars
ans en 2021 que de dire qu'on va aller
sur la lune en 1961 si vous voulez ce
qui est vrai par contre c'est que il
faut développer énormément de choses
beaucoup de matériel c'est à dire un
vaisseau spatial capable de faire le
voyage aller où le voyage a laissé six
mois sept mois c'est comparable aux
séjours typique dans la station spatiale
internationale
ensuite faut descendre à la surface sert
présente quelques difficultés faut vivre
à la surface à surface on est quand même
déjà bien protégé un sur mars de des
radiations par exemple mais c'est
compliqué on va vivre plusieurs mois ce
pas facile il faut une fusée pour
décoller et faut rentrer donc c'est
d'une très grande difficulté mais ya moi
je ne vois pas d'impossibilité on va
évoquer certains problèmes
psychologiques et surtout médicaux avec
les promus radiations mais honnêtement
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de limite donc
je suis plutôt on a légèrement en
désaccord par contre la première
difficulté c'est de développer tout ça
ça demande énormément de moyens
financiers et bafoue faut les trouver
alors pendant très longtemps on
imaginait qu'il faudrait un espèce de
nouveaux kennedy qui disent on va aller
sur mars
on va investir des sommes énormes et
donc ça c'est pas possible ça n'arrivera
pas mais on commence maintenant à
réaliser que grâce à des améliorations
techniques affectivement des gens comme
elle admet ce qui secoue le cocotier que
c'est envisageable avec un budget de la
nasa de lézat et s'est légèrement
croissant mais rien de révolutionnaire à
terme je mentionnerai aussi que
personnellement je fais partie avec
certains collègues de gens qui proposent
que avant de faire une mission à la
surface de mars on fasse déjà des
missions assez intéressante en ce
mettant en orbite autour de mars
c'est intéressant parce qu'on peut
accoster des petites lunes de mars
s'appelle phobos et deimos on peut aussi
piloter en temps réel les robots à la
surface qui sont comme des avatars si
vous voulez alors qu'actuellement mars
est toujours tellement loin qu'on peut
pas le faire en temps réel c'est sa
limite énormément de les capacités de
nos robots donc sa fin c'est une sereine
expédition extraordinaire beaucoup plus
facile à ces dangereuses mais qui est
envisageable elle dans dans quand même
dans les années
[Musique]